probably more changing the way the world
the people of the world communicating
work with each other it will have
effects on everything from our society
to our businesses to our family life how
we educate our children how we learn
from others how we improve our social
justice systems how we are able to
become better negotiators and avoid
future military conflicts and become
better citizens of the world it will
expand and then and and encompass almost
every aspect of human communication
cooperation in world events it is today
probably one of the largest influences
on those matters and it will just be all
encompassing over the decades in the
linear response
you